let's make one of my favorite chinese
takeout dishes beef broccoli okay i have
to start with this because i've always
wondered how the beef and beef broccoli
got so soft and it's baking soda it
helps to tenderize the meat we're gonna
let that sit for like 30 minutes let's
make the sauce broth dark soy sauce
oyster sauce sugar sesame oil and a dash
of white pepper mix it all up and now
we're gonna branch the broccoli for
about 20 seconds we still want it
crunchy i love that this dish is
uniquely chinese american because this
dish originally uses chinese broccoli
but when chinese immigrants were making
this dish here in the states it was a
little harder to find chinese broccoli
if you're imagining what chinese
broccoli looks like it's very stemi if
you've seen broccolini broccolini is a
hybrid between broccoli and chinese
broccoli but yeah ever since it was
replaced with broccoli florets it kind
of became a staple and you know what
they say if it's not broke don't fix it
cheers
the beef is so tender broccoli's nice
and crunchy